so today's topic amber Geiger Geiger
shot and killed an innocent man in his
own apartment she said she thought she
had walked into her own apartment she
had been facing ninety-nine years in
prison she was sentenced to 10 years
eligible for parole in five so if you
aren't aware every Geiger and her
lawyers have just started the process
for an appeal of course she says she
feels she doesn't deserve the chance to
be with her family friends well you say
that and then when you're giving your
just possible punishment you're saying
it's not right I deserve less punishment
how does that make sense and what makes
the matter worse is that for this
appeals case a key witness is now dead
right so now the appeals process is far
more likely to be successful if they can
discredit one of the witnesses
testimonies they want to move the trial
from Dallas to somewhere else why but it
made me make me mean because of the fact
that Dallas has too much of a black
population and and some people of course
yeah
cuz it biases the jury excuse me when
black defendants have to go up and it's
mostly a white jury do we say that this
jury is how somehow miced oh oh but now
that might be a lot of black people you
guys have a problem with it okay
everyone has seen the video of the
brother hugging her so already right now
all the potential jurors that you're
gonna have in the future are going to be
biased and they're going to be leaning
towards forgiveness and that same hug is
probably gonna help with the appeals
process after hearing about how his
family talked about him I don't think
beau would want to take harsh vengeance
I think he would want to forgive her I
just have a big problem with family
members speaking on behalf of someone
who's dead and you shouldn't have the
right to decide whether or not their
killer gets to go free nobody
oh dang I just tell everybody you guys
want to get all this kumbaya training
you guys want to engage in all this acts
our forgiveness all this other nonsense
right but look what happens now
now what ends up happening is that
you've devalued the crime that exists
when someone takes a life of a black man
when a police officer [ __ ] up
you guys have D value what kind of
proper punishment that they should have
because you guys want to engage in your
Christian beliefs in the courtroom
listen I believe in the idea of
separation of church and state you want
to have a religious ceremony you keep
that [ __ ] out of the courtroom I don't
want to hear none of that stuff because
I didn't today we need a functioning
society and the site isn't function
based off your ideas of forgiveness
alone she's gonna disappear goes through
I'm very I believe she's gonna get even
through her crime and her moment of
sorrow you see how fake she's being with
I I thought this person in my apartment
not in the apartment I mistakenly
walking to who belong to somebody else
but my bum you were scared how do you
think both of was when he found you
walking into his apartment in the truth
was she gets ten years probably five
with probation nobody and now she's
filing for an appeal so it was all an
act and you black people were all about
that forgiveness you bought into it
that's it for today's video I want to
write the news I just want to share it
with you guys so we wonder what you guys
think are you guys fine with amber that
you're going through with this appeal do
feels hypocritical or whatnot we want to
know your comments below and also what
do you think would you want your family
members hugging the person who killed
you even if it was accidental we want to
hear your thoughts bone
[Music]
in regard
ever since she killed that man she has
not been the same she show remorse and
that she's gonna have to deal with that
for the rest of her life I will never be
able to get some finesse that kind of
sympathy I'm it sounds like how a game
of appearance it is in order all right
I remember one day one of my friends he
got a DUI I went to support him in the
verdict of his DUI I go in there and his
lawyer looks at me he's like oh you're
his friend yeah you're not gonna be able
to get in and I'm like why well because
that's a game okay I'm trying to give
him the best image that he could have
and you being next to him it's not gonna
give that much of a good image I was not
the one that did the cry but in order to
support my friend I had to stay outside
of the courtroom because of how I look